let's talk about a movie trailer the
movie trailer to battle right the Hunger
Games all right so everyone I know on
YouTube messages me and they're like
dude are you hyped for The Hunger Games
realistically well it looks cool but I
have never read the book which is stupid
because everyone I know who has read
that book has never said anything bad
about it in fact my friend has the
trilogy he plopped it in my lap and he
was like rated dude but I haven't why
Skyrim that's why however four week
common folk who have not read the book
there's now what trailer what yeah there
was a trailer that came out a few months
ago but all the showed was that chick
shooting a bow and arrow that was it now
the chick shoots a bow and arrow that do
with the creepy beard notices and that
is better right so the Hunger Games
takes place in the future and it looks
like a bleak ass future they usually are
it's good to know that it doesn't get
any better than this
don't look forward too much in the
future ladies and gentlemen and there
are a lot of zones and each zone picks a
couple of names and those names those
winners get to compete in Hunger Games
for life and death which is funny
because everyone compares the books to
Twilight's like oh dudes just the next
Twilight I already heard about the
premise of the books and I thought
that's nothing like Twilight now that
I've seen the trailer I can say it's
nothing like Twilight not even a little
bit not even kind of a little bit one
hour on a weekend at 4 a.m. with the
infomercials and Twilight bad actors day
in Hunger Games better actors die which
I'm not gonna lie who's intrigued by
that premise kids dying yep sadistic
bastard I'm fine with it though but
honestly speaking the trailer looks
really good this little girl gets picked
to be in The Hunger Games in the main
chicks like No I'll do it I'll take your
place I didn't know that happened that's
cool it just makes it a little more
intriguing and her just getting her name
drawn and in the drawing I was like oh
sweet Lady gaga does still have a job in
the future
and this event is a big show it's like
Smash TV anytime there's a future in
which people play games and die I should
think Running Man but I think Smash TV
why I don't know I guess I'm just that
awesome and so all these kids battle to
the death to put on a big show for all
the people watching to win the Hunger
Games it shows I'm training to be ninjas
and slicing off mannequin heads when you
put that together when you're like all
right kids are gonna compete and he
sliced off a mannequin head ooh kids
gonna lose his head then you just get
excited make it awesome make that kid
lose his head drop a rock on piggies
face Lord of the Flies right wrong movie
I'm going
dai I want to still be me I just can't
afford to think like that yeah you can't
because you're a badass who has to win
the Hunger Games and kill kids if she
kills kids I don't know if she does and
Woody Harrelson's wig really freaked you
out when I got really excited in the
trailer is when they started bringing in
s ride the bagpipe music it's 24 of us
Gale only one comes out
I am in and I really like the nd n just
builds the tension you see them raising
up from the ground the countdown is
going on and then the race is on rollin
grab your [ __ ] get into the woods
because kids are gonna kill you now
because kids are just bad people so I'm
excited for the Hunger Games yeah it
looks awesome plus the logo is badass
I don't know why I like cool logos
alright so the Hunger Games have you
read the book have you read all the
books what did you think of them and are
you looking forward to this movie
comment below let me know and a lot of
you have been asking questions about the
you reviewers movie awards for those of
you who remember the you reviewers movie
awards was an award show put on last
year by schmoes know and myself where we
got a lot of the YouTube reviewing
community together and we did our own
award show because we were like that's
just way cooler than you know the Oscars
more announcements are going to be
coming out soon but recently I did a
podcast with the schmoes in which we
talked about it so I put a link below to
that podcast might answer some questions
you guys may have about it so tell your
friends because you reviewers movie
awards part 2 is coming and as always if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you